now to campaign 2020 and the final push
by president trump and joe biden to
rally support
with just six days to go before election
day
the two candidates and their running
mates held 10 events yesterday
in seven states although with very
different styles due to the coronavirus
as ed o'keefe reports the biden strategy
includes states like
georgia that democrats haven't won in
decades
now nebraska we know it's looking great
okay campaigning in nebraska late
tuesday president trump
slammed his opponent if biden wins he
will
do bad things by the way
he's not a good guy just so you
understand earlier former vice president
joe biden spent tuesday night rallying
supporters in atlanta
making his first stop in georgia as the
democratic nominee
our work is hard for those who don't
support me as those who do
that's the job of a president a duty to
care for everyone
biden is currently tied with the
president in georgia and if he were to
win there he'd be the first democrat to
do so
since 1992. something's happening
here in georgia and across america
[Applause]
people of different races backgrounds
democrats republicans independents
they're coming together also on the
campaign trail first lady melania trump
who visited pennsylvania for her first
solo campaign appearance this year
and defended her husband's social media
habits
i do not always agree what the way he
says
things
but it is important to him that he
speaks directly to the people he serves
already an estimated 71 million
americans have voted early
shattering previous records early
indications are that more of the early
voters casting their ballots by mail
are democrats while more republicans
vote early in person
it doesn't have to start on tuesday it
could start earlier
early voting you want to be there mr
trump also complained that the election
has focused
too much on his response to the pandemic
covenant you're turning the news
covert coven that caught the attention
of his predecessor
kovitt kovetkova he's complaining he's
jealous
of kovid's media coverage former
president barack obama
campaigning in orlando if he had been
focused on kovit from the beginning
cases wouldn't be reaching new record
highs across the country
this week biden is home today in
delaware but his campaign says he'll be
getting a briefing on the pandemic from
public health officials
and then give remarks on the federal
response to the coronavirus
the president meanwhile plans to visit
10 states in the closing days of the
campaign
and his team says he plans 11 in-person
rallies
in the 48 hours leading up to election
day tony
very busy schedule ed thank you very
much